you wouldn't believe this lucas we
interviewed noam chomsky about a month
ago wow and uh the recording [ __ ] up
ah ah oh my god
we've had to deep fake him and we've
done such an amazing job of it that
chomsky has allowed us to release it
[Laughter]
yeah it took a lot of time though to do
that
you really did that i thought you were
joking
oh my god we totally deep faked him
it wasn't i don't call it a deep fake it
was it was a deep clone we cloned him to
reconstruct what he said
wow oh yeah it was still his words
but everything else was uh yeah
synthesized in his video we just we just
had to time warp it to get it to lip
sync
so you had uh audio at least
no the audio was the thing that was like
probably corrupted so we had to
painstakingly
listen to it and and spend hours and
hours human transcribing an accurate
transcript and then tim
tim trained a uh you know a clone of his
voice and then
speak that voice and then we had to
re-auto transcribe it to get the
nanosecond timings of it and then do
this time warping to lip sync it with
the video and it was it was a disaster
man i wanted i want to see this
that that was like that was yeah it's
good it's going to be worth it it was
yeah yeah it was quite an experience
lucas b world is an entrepreneur living
in san francisco he was the founder and
ceo of figure 8 an internet company that
collects training data for machine
learning
which he co-founded in 2007. in 2019 he
sold figure 8 for a cool 300 million
dollars
in 2018 he founded weights and biases
henceforth known as 1db it's very
important remember that a company that
creates developer tools for machine
learning now recently 1db got a cash
injection of 15 million dollars
but most of which have been given to us
through sponsorship i might add in its
second funding round
as many of you folks know uh 1db
sponsored the lacoon show and the benjio
show and also the as yet unreleased to
david harsh show now lucas also hosts
his own podcast called gradient descent
it's absolutely amazing you must go and
check it out
i prefer to watch it on the youtube
channel because you can see the video as
well and he recently just interviewed
the ceo of nvidia which is pretty
amazing
lucas has a bachelor's and a masters in
mathematics and computer science
respectively from stanford university
and he was a research student under the
tutelage of the legendary daphne collar
which is amazing anyway lucas thank you
so much for coming on mlst welcome
thank you thank you
thanks for having me cool
well why don't you start i mean can you
tell us a bit about your personal story
and how you managed to build two very
successful startups
um
well i appreciate the the framing of
that question that's that's quite nice
um
i um
you know i'm not sure i mean i you know
i i started my first company back in in
2008 as the market was collapsing and
you know it it wasn't like
you know oh i'm this person that really
needs to start a company it was like
man you know all the interesting
research is driven by the training data
that's available
people just keep using the same training
data sets you know over and over and
over to death and they're they're all
flawed in specific ways
and so you know i really thought that
the best thing i could offer the world
was helping
um
companies get access to training that
actually actually fit their
needs
and um
you know i ran it for for a long time
and and um you know lots of things
happened turns out harder to build a
company than you think
um and then um you know
you know and then as that um kind of
came to close and we and we sold it
started thinking about you know uh what
did i really enjoy about it and and the
thing that i really loved about
running um my previous company was that
was just the the the chance to work with
so many really smart ml researchers i
mean i had obviously a taste of that um
working with daphne and then in my first
job but um you know it was it was
actually you know it's funny ceo you get
a little out of date pretty quickly
especially in ml and so you know i
hadn't really been like you know
watching
how amazingly well deep learning was
working and i was a go player
as a kid and so
i thought a lot about how you would make
a computer beat um a human at go
and and really seeing um alphago when it
when it beat lisa doll um you know it
just blew my mind and i was just
thinking wow they're just like
you know finally like machine learning
is like really really working you know
for for applications besides you know
ranking advertisements and um
you know i just i just really wanted to
help um and kind of help make that work
it's then you know i was kind of
tinkering myself like building models
and
you know i was surprised that
i think it's actually harder to train
models now
than it was when i was a student back in
in 2004 right like you know you run into
like like linker errors and i'm like
digging deep into my you know computer
science past to like remember even
what's a what's a linker like how do i
even like deal with this
um and so it just seemed like actually
despite ml getting more powerful
it also got like a lot harder like the
tooling seemed even kind of more broken
um than it than it was you know
the last time i was training lots of
models and so you know i kind of
couldn't help myself but start another
company that um that set out to address
that and just sort of make ml
engineers ml practitioners whatever you
want to call it lives easier and every
kind of step with the the model training
and deployment process
so maybe uh this is a kind of fun
question before we dive into into the
more
you know deeper technical things uh you
and i you and i and tim as well share
this this passion for games and really a
deep interest
in games i would say and of course we've
had tremendous success in teaching
computers how to play games as you
mentioned
um but one area that's always frustrated
me personally as a gamer is the
neverending problem of game balance
right like especially the seemingly
inevitable
swinging pendulum when the when the
designers try to go back and rebalance
the game and you know fix fix the
balance problems have you ever wondered
could game designers use ai to actually
help us create better optimized more
diverse balanced game rules and
mechanics themselves and have you seen
any examples of that and if not what do
you think the barrier is
yeah you know i mean we literally work
with most of the bigger gaming companies
and they they tell us this is one of
their important um
applications it's funny because i'm not
like a huge computer gamer like there's
certain games that i really love um but
you know some of these companies come in
and
you know like to to a lot of the people
at weights and biases they're like oh my
god that is like the the biggest deal
like we closed you know the the people
that make like you know world of
warcraft and i feel like that's a little
bit not on my um radar it's just not
like a game i got super um into and i
don't know if they specifically use us
for balance but i actually think that's
an important application
of um uh ml and reinforcement learning
right now i guess i'd prefer to let the
the companies themselves talk about
exactly how that works as much as
they're comfortable and i'm sure they
are somewhere but i think that's a
that's something that we've seen um you
know several times with bigger companies
and lots of times with startups so
that's that's definitely going on right
now good there's hope for us then
but it's uh do you kind of feel like
you're being manipulated like i
sometimes feel like what a game feel
like feels like it's balancing live i'm
like come on like
make it harder i guess i guess the
balance is sort of like making sure
there's not like a hack to like
um
you know to to win it um
actually you know you know um you know
who's a huge gamer is andre carpath i
don't know if you've had him on
um on your show but he was actually
talking to me just the other the other
day about um wishing that that there was
more balance in games and he had some
ideas around using reinforcement
learning for that so i don't know he may
be interested in that too
amazing i'd love it if andre came on the
show um consider this your invitation i
did [ __ ] post him a bit on twitter the
other day so he might know what's going
on but um
and by by the way we're all being
manipulated
um
i want to ask you a bunch of questions
about 1db i've got loads of them written
down but
first of all i want to test your metal
as a ceo and your pitching skills can
you give me the 30 seconds elevator
pitch for 1db
well so it depends on the audience so
who are you are you like a like a
business person are you like an ml
engineer like what's your
what's who am i talking about here that
you're absolutely right that was the
correct that was the correct answer um
let's say i am an ml engineer
well if you're a double engineer um
what i'll tell you is the most important
thing is i want you to use it it's like
we say it's five lines of code it's
actually one line of code with most
popular frameworks so it's so easy to
use you really should just try it and
the first thing that it'll do for you
is it'll basically save the information
that happens in your models as they
train so that's like the simplest setup
right so you know you'll know i mean
you've all like written down the hyper
parameters you used and the state of the
code and then tried to go back and rerun
training and everyone thinks
reproducibility is important and yet no
one keeps careful enough track to go
back a week from a week ago or a month
ago and really rerun a model and if you
add those couple lines of code um to
your training runs you'll get that for
free and forever right so you know you
could trade a million models you want to
roll back like
10 000 models ago no problem you can do
it that's like the first thing that
you'll enjoy about the product and and i
want you to do that but then i think the
real value happens when you can use that
same stuff to communicate with the rest
of your team right so now you can pull
up any model and pull up like a
beautiful graph of what it's doing dig
into like how it's using the gpu kind of
whatever is relevant and the salt
postdoc analysis and you can share it
broadly in a stable place where your
findings are not going to go away right
so not only do you have record the model
training but you now have like a record
of what you what you learned
especially the things you know that
didn't work that you know you might not
take the time to write down or write a
research paper um and then from there we
do tons of other stuff these days we do
um you know we have like a model
registry that we just launched and we
have um some data exploration stuff so
we're building like a full suite of
stuff but um my main point is it's very
very easy to start take less than five
minutes and you'll thank yourself
amazing yeah um
there's a real problem with machine
learning projects in general i mean
software engineering is hard enough but
i think people misunderestimate the
brittleness like if you change one tiny
little thing over there you can no
longer reproduce what you've done but um
i wanted to talk about what i see as the
other big problem uh you know because i
kind of think of ml devops as the
implementation of software engineering
rigor basically yeah you know and i
agree totally say technical excellence
at scale for machine learning but there
are so many challenges and and i think
the biggest one for me has always been
the cultural dichotomy between science
and engineering and agile and software
engineering best practices are anathema
to data scientists so um how do you
overcome that hurdle
i think you have to have a lot of
empathy from for where everyone's coming
from and i think that's one of the
reasons that weights and biases has been
successful is you know i come from like
a more ml researcher background
and um my co-founder sean you know has
much i mean they always make fun of me
they're like lucas doesn't know how git
works he just types in like random git
commands like until he like you know
gets his state so messed up that we have
to go in and like help him but it's
actually i think that's like eye opening
for for sean because git is so like
obvious you know to him how it works
that i think in sort of like fixing my
um get problems he actually kind of
learned like oh you know these
researchers they're really smart
um but they don't understand a lot of
things about how the the machine
you know actually actually functions
right they get you know nervous when
you know they get like weird linker
errors you know and so um i i think
there has to be a lot of empathy and i
do think ml engineers have to unlearn
a lot of bad habits that they pick up in
school because like you know in school
you're sort of racing to get a research
paper out and then the code is thrown
away whereas you know in a work
environment
most of what you do is like after you
know you you train the model the first
time right so um but i i think like
tooling here can really help like for
example you know we save a lot in the
background quietly by default you know
and um and i think that's really
important right like you know if you're
counting on someone to kind of like
you know keep careful track of
everything that they do it's just never
gonna work it's just human nature right
like you you have to have the stuff
happen quietly
um in the background so you know we got
a lot of companies where people like oh
why do i want some weights of biases i
just i think a spreadsheet of all the
hyper parameters i use it kind of works
for me this seems like overhead
and it's like well you have that now
maybe if you're really diligent right
but then you hire a second person are
they gonna do that then you leave and a
third person starts so you understand
what you know what you were doing so um
i think there's a lot of um
power of automation and i think
you know i think like people resist bad
tools that get in your way as they
should right so like you know you could
help someone with like you know
versioning their models
but or you know you can have total
reproducibility if you're willing to
follow exactly my system right so if you
do like all the things i tell you it's
not hard from a computer science
perspective it's like hard from like a
human nature perspective right so you
know reproducibility is easy but you
know reproducibility without adding like
a ton of overhead for you is is really
hard and so i think the ml ops teams are
like hey why don't these crazy
researchers just like settle down and
follow you know standard practices but
of course you know the researchers are
trying to like you know produce these
models and move things forward and
overhead is like really frustrating um
and i think they also are kind of like
well what are these why are the you know
why are the ops people trying to like
out all this like process and like
trouble for me but again i do think
there's like pareto optimal improvements
to be done here by just like you know
making good reliable tooling that stays
out of the um yeah out of everybody's
way
well so let me ask you a bit more about
that because there is really this almost
central conflict which is for the
researchers you know they're they're
futzing around and meandering and trying
kind of all different sorts of things
and and it is great to have a tool that
tracks
everything that they're up to but on the
other hand the downside is it's
literally
tracking everything like it's going to
say you know jill's modeled 11 a.m
before lunch and jill's model at 202 pm
after lunch and all those kinds of
minutiae and all the little things that
that it's tracking they they can be
important for the individual
researcher
if they need to go back but downstream
those artifacts are almost too fine
grained and somehow the artifact graph
has has to be kind of highly filtered
and aggregated or simplified for it to
have any
real relevance to what's going on
downstream and say the outputs of groups
or organizations
um as a whole do you agree with that and
what's your vision for for how the
tooling can get better to help collapse
some of that history into really just
the the history that that matters at
least for certain views
yeah look it's a real challenge um i
think that you know our point of view is
that we want to track as much as we
possibly can um by default because
search can be really powerful right and
so you know for if we're capturing a lot
and we're making it kind of easy to
explore what happened at least you have
some comfort there right like i don't
very often go and interrogate deep into
my git log you know but the times i do
boy i'm so happy that something was just
like quietly you know saving the changes
behind the scenes and i do think ml
in particular like you know you always
hear about these bugs where it's like
two weeks ago you know someone was doing
something else they messed something up
invalidated you know my last couple
weeks of work but i don't know exactly
how many you know weeks and like i don't
know you know exactly what i should
throw out and so um you know that's kind
of like a core use case of of weights
and biases it's not fun but it's like
really really important you know for
making it a useful product for um you
know the mo researcher or ml engineer i
think there's this other step though
which i would sort of describe as like
kind of communicating with the
organization
which i actually think is a huge piece
of
um
most ml researchers when they're when
they're in
um you know really an industry it's a
huge piece of their their function is
like hey you know what am i doing like
what are my models training on like what
are sort of the important milestones
when did i like you know push a
particular model to to production
and so we try to do there is make it
really easy
for
the ml engineer to communicate what
they're doing kind of curate what
they're doing right and so you know we
have a product that's really well loved
called reports that yeah it doesn't fit
neatly in those like workflow diagrams
that every vc you know comes out with
and you know it but but i actually think
it's kind of the
our customers tell us it's their
favorite part of weights and biases is
these reports where you can basically
kind of pull out
um like a lineage of of models and we
found that people really like to curate
that right so like you know we were just
saying hey you have this workspace with
all your models why don't you just want
to share that and you can
um but customers kept asking how do i
kind of like you know curate the six
models that i trained that's like making
a particular point you know that i want
to make but still have that that lineage
and so we spent quite a lot of time on
making that work because so many
customers um you know come in and use
that and you know i wish we could
automate it but i kind of think you
can't really automate that like human to
human
communication like i think in the end
that might be the last function that um
ml practitioners will be doing right
like you know even if you're just sort
of like you know doing prompt
engineering on um you know gbt3 or
something you still need that
that um communication step but i'm not
sure you know like where the space goes
but i i
um anyway i do think that's critical
that that's interesting yeah i mean this
this touches on two things i wanted to
ask you about the first thing that keith
was just talking on is uh i mean what
1db is wonderful for knowledge sharing
but there's horizontal knowledge sharing
and there's vertical knowledge sharing
and i mean i work in a large enterprise
and the the leadership want to um
consume increasingly abstract
information right you know which
represents the status of many downstream
uh projects and as you just said you
know the the way that the kind of um
inter-project knowledge sharing happens
in in 1db is quite open-ended because
it's through the interface of the
reports so i wondered whether you could
just touch on that first that um quite
often in the large enterprise you get a
group it function the first thing they
want to do is come up with a rubric and
it will be quite abstract so it would be
how are we doing on safety how are we
doing on security how we did genotyping
and and somehow all of this information
needs to magically go up the funnel and
fit into that rubric um how would that
work with 1db
yeah i mean it's something that i love
to support because i think i have
empathy for both the you know ml
engineer and the the leadership here so
i feel like we we should be able to do
this well
um and you know i think i mean
leadership loves seeing a graph that's
going up and to the right and so we we
help you make that graph right so you
can kind of pull out the different you
know models that you've trained in the
metrics that you care about and those
metrics could be ones that you valued at
the time of training or they could be
kind of post-hoc analyses that you did
um on your models and you know we make
it easy i mean these aren't like genius
data visualizations right these are sort
of like scatter plots and graphs that
are like you know easy to consume
um but again i think we make them very
very easy to make and and kind of make
them accurately um and so and i think
very importantly we make it really easy
to put a lot of text around them right
because it's like if you're just you
know setting a graph
without the context um like i think like
having a fully featured
text editor
is actually really critical for for good
communication um inside organizations
and so again you might say well why does
weights and biases have its own um
you know text editor we put a lot of
time into it but you know i think it
turns out that if you want to
communicate well
you know letting people use different
size text really matters right like you
know like engineers might be okay with
just sort of like mark down
you know but communicating broadly in
the organization you know you want to be
able to have a richer um experience and
and i think like
you know it's something that um
that i want to figure out how to support
even better because i i care about a lot
it's a really it's a really really
important part of making
um
you know helping the ml teams actually
make stuff that's useful that people
really use
fantastic fantastic i mean coming back
to this enterprise customers topics it's
a particular interest to me
um one of the biggest things which comes
up time and time again is around
topology so should systems be
decentralized or should they be
centralized or even something between
the two extremes and um you know so i
guess i'm saying like should there be
one 1db workspace for the entire um
company or one per business
and typically i find that many vertical
kind of business units they resist all
forms of centralization right as they
see it as to friction inducing and they
cite security concerns however the
central it function they think it's a
brilliant idea because it gives them
more control but also it fosters
collaboration information sharing and
and so on and so forth so do you have a
slant one way or the other
well i'll say as a as an entrepreneur
that's that's trying to sell a product i
mean our customers have such a strong
um point of view
here that we have to support you know
both ways of operating because like
you know i mean we work with apple and i
think it's like
you know they they have like data
security that doesn't let them share you
know even with with other teams and so
um you know just be impossible to have
like a centralized um you know weights
and biases um product product for them
even if you know if there is benefit to
it i think
um you know other teams um yeah like
you're saying they really like to
centralize and i would just say from my
vantage point
um i think that you see
companies operating in different ways
because there's really big
pros and cons to how you actually want
to structure your
ml function right like you know
ml you know ml
researchers kind of like to work
together right and so you know you'll
see like you know like meadow with fair
like kind of putting them all in one um
function but of course when you put them
all together
you know they just naturally get a
little bit disconnected from
um the the individual teams and what the
company is trying to do which is really
you know dangerous right you know you
can end up like you know optimizing the
wrong thing right we see that all the
time and so there's this really um
strong tension and i think people notice
the problem so i mean you know we've
i've been doing this long enough that
i've watched a lot of our customers just
go back and forth right they distribute
you know the ml team's like into their
organization and then they pull it back
out and centralize and they distribute
and then they pull it back out and i i
think that you can't honestly say
um that there's really a best practice
here because um
you know companies like just just do it
both ways and it's sort of like you pick
pick your poison of like you know which
are you more worried about like if
you're more worried about kind of like
hiring and talent i think it's more
important to centralize if you're more
worried about um making like use cases
actually connect with what you're trying
to do then you want to decentralize it
and i think the weights and biases
installs
typically reflect
the the customer's org chart right so
like the the companies that have you
know really centralized teams will tend
to have kind of one
um you know big install like you know
fair has like one weights and biases um
server it's awesome they can like share
all their work it's super cool you know
um
and then but then um you know other
companies will have like lots of
installs in some cases you know they
don't even know about
you know what the other teams are doing
and i think weights advice is actually
conserve a funny function of just sort
of like letting you know ml teams know
about other ml teams at their own
um you know company when the company's
large enough
fantastic um i wanted to ask you about
um you know the perennial challenge of
generalization versus specialization
especially in respect of some of this uh
um you know kind of templatization and
standardization that we've been talking
about so um i see this all the time i
mean when i build ml devops systems or
templates um people expect to have a
general abstraction or blueprint that
just works in every single situation but
and also in the way that we report
information to leaders as we just spoke
about and the biggest sticking point i
find is that teams prefer specialization
they hate generalization because they
don't think that they're a cookie cutter
they quickly feel that the operating
model no longer applies to them and this
is why it's so bloody difficult to make
ml devops systems work at scale um i
just wondered did you have any any
thoughts on that
yeah i mean i i think that you well if
your weights and biases you really have
to do to do both i actually think that
probably bigger mlops functions really
should should do both like i think that
you know people do want to
i mean ml
engineers in particular
want to do all kinds of weird stuff and
they want a general tool you know
there's just like there's no getting
around it that's like what everybody
wants and i think they should want that
just because the the feel has changed so
fast that if you have a team that's like
willing to just sort of like sit like
fit into a straight jacket you're
probably gonna miss out on on new stuff
that's that's coming
and so that's why we we actually have a
a platform that's really sort of two
tiers right there's like you know kind
of like a lower level tier that's sort
of like basic building blocks
and we actually at weights and biases
then use those building blocks to build
things that are like more solution
oriented and more of a point of view and
it kind of helps us because we can kind
of quickly build you know new stuff
because in a way
you know like like a database a data set
registry it's pretty similar to a model
registry you know and like functionally
but it's you know there's some details
that that would make you know make them
very very different right and if you
don't get those right if you're just
like hey i have like an arbitrary object
registry that's not a very good
experience you know for for a customer
so i think like framing it here's our
database registry here data set register
here's our model registry you know works
better but if you if we build those
internally off the same building blocks
we can also say you know what
like we have these registry building
blocks that we use to make our data set
registry and our in our model registry
like if you have something else that you
you know care about and want to track
you can um build that or for example
with our ui tools you know we build them
on um
you know something called vega which is
a very very kind of low level um you
know essentially like you know
um visualization building framework and
so you know we had a bunch of
visualizations but at some point we're
just you know what we'll just expose the
vega right if you really want to get in
there and make some crazy visualization
you know
that's great we love it you know like um
but but you know you're going down into
the raw vegas so like i think that helps
a lot with like the
the learning curve and i think it
actually gives a lot of people
um
comfort like i think a lot of ml
engineers they just want to know that
they're not going to get like stuck like
they want to know that they have like a
way
you know to if if for some weird reason
they want to do something crazy that'll
be available to them but then they kind
of end up like i feel like i've built a
lot of stuff like um
you know jeremy howard suggested this
like parameter importance
um plot where it's just like you build a
um like a random forest on top of your
um
uh hyper parameters where you predict
some number
um and then or particularly isometric
and then you just looks it kind of shows
you what parameters what hyper
parameters are kind of more important
across like the models that you trained
and everyone was like oh that's like too
simple i could do that trivially in like
a notebook
and like um
you know like i need to do like more
advanced stuff
but by just like making that you know
it's like actually like
tons of our customers use it including
like our most advanced customers that
were like you know we need something
custom
and um
and so like when you actually watch what
people do versus what people say they're
gonna do
you know it can be pretty different
right so like you know you can export
all your model data anytime you can ask
for all your hyper parameters you can
make your own crazy um you know way of
detecting what's the best hyper prayer
if you do that let me know and be
curious about it but i think by just
making it really easy to get a simple
feel for like you know which which hyper
primer is the most important turns out
most people end up using it if it's like
you know well done and easy to get
started or like i mean it's so funny
like i mean hyper promotization is
another one like people always tell me
like hey do you support this new crazy
sweep algorithm and like you know here's
the thing most people are doing grid
search i'm just trying to get people to
use bayesian optimization and that's
like actually like you know
significantly better it's a free
um improvement we offer it for free you
know um
but like people kind of stick to
grid search so until we get more people
doing like bayesian optimization
you know it's kind of like well i'm not
sure if we need to like you know kind of
go to something even more exotic at this
at this point although we would love to
so we probably will you you kind of went
to right to an area i wanted to ask
about which is in the spirit of um
you know making the right thing easy to
do and available
uh
what do you see what's your vision for
increasing the tools that weights and
biases offers around
model explainability
ai ethics you know just making it much
easier for people to understand what
their models are doing and that they're
doing really what they should be doing
from not just correctness perspective
but but ethical concerns as well
yeah i mean it's something that i really
care about personally a lot of the
people at weights and biases really um
cares about i think that uh
you know i want to be like respectful
for the amount of like good work
that's out there that people don't use i
mean it kind of reminds me of like um
you know hyper parameter search in a way
where like shop is like this incredible
project that gives you like all this
explainability stuff and yet
you know most of our customers aren't
using it it's like free it's easy to
install you know it's like you know
it'll take you like
i don't know almost like an hour to like
set it up and and and get it running so
i think like a big part of what i want
weights advice is to offer is like make
it really easy to use
um
the good stuff that exists today because
i think like even an hour of somebody's
time there's a cognitive overhead to
trying something new
um so
i i want to make this stuff like simpler
to use i also think that like
people
people want to build
i think really advanced
um
explainability stuff and i think it's
great like i i
would not knock anyone for that i think
it's really interesting direction of
research
but if you look at what people are
really doing and like where they get
into trouble it's like pretty basic
stuff that they would have seen
if they were you know kind of
consistently checking the performance of
their model across um
like lots of types of um data sets right
like you know the stuff that you hear in
the news you know it'll be like okay
you know
face detection didn't work as well on on
black people's faces right or like you
know like voice um
uh transcription doesn't work you know
well with people with like a
non-standard accent or like not the
american
you know um
you know the the kind of standard
midwest uh newscaster accent or whatever
it is and it's like that actually
those examples make the news
for sure and they're they're really bad
i mean people really should be concerned
about that and i think that problems
getting worse but it's actually i think
it's like almost exactly the same
problem that like every company faces
where they roll out a thing that's like
broken for like a group of their um
customers right so it shows you that
it's it's not like um
i don't think it's like really like this
like um
people are certainly not trying to do it
and they certainly need to like fix it
and they're not fixing it there and
they're not fixing it all over the place
where it like
really really clearly like you know
hurts their business and and i think
that the reason that they don't is
actually it's more about
um having like kind of systematic simple
processes
than a really advanced
um
visualization so like that's why i
actually think that the the best thing
that we can offer
is just like saving all the models
making it really easy to run apples to
apples evaluation comparisons
and it's like you don't need like a
crazy visualization or something special
it's just like literally a table right
of like let's like cut you know all the
different groups of people that like you
know might be like engaging you know
with this um
use case and like you know what's the
accuracy like where is it low you should
look at that right like you know if you
release a new model did the accuracy
drop on like any particular group right
you should you should know about that
you know you should know about it for
ethics reasons absolutely
you know even if you're in a domain
where you you don't think that there's
an ethical
issue you should you should be um
you know checking that and i think i
think that people typically will check
it like once or twice but actually what
you need is check it consistently and so
there i really do think there's a ton of
value just making it easy to do
the basic
um analyses that you should be doing um
anyway so like that that's that's kind
of my my perspective yeah they think
like
guys like shop is like free you know
it's it's open tourists it's great like
well you should use it
um
i mean i've got a i've got a beautiful
question for you lucas i genuinely i
don't know where you're gonna fall on
this question but uh we've done a show
we interviewed christoph mulnard about
interpretability the problem with chap
and shapley values is um it requires a
fair bit of expertise it means it's
complicated mathematics to explain
complicated mathematics and we were just
saying before about depending on who the
stakeholder is we're sharing information
but the information has to be
understandable by those stakeholders um
which means it needs to be presented
differently but um you were just saying
i mean there's this dichotomy you know
around should we try and understand the
machine or should we just look at the
outputs like accuracy and i'm torn on
this because i quite often hear the
argument oh um an
airplane pilot doesn't need to
understand how the engine works right
because you know they just do 10 000
hours of flying and they just know the
plane's not going to crash but i would
argue that um you know these engines
aren't brittle they're not brittle like
machine learning models are right and
you only have to look at the benchmarks
in natural language processing to
realize that optimizing benchmarks is
the road to nowhere so do you think that
we should be taking more you know more
of an effort to understand the machine
itself
um
well i i just want to say i'm not like
the world's expert on this topic so i
can pontificate a little bit but i i
want to reserve the right to change my
mind or you know if someone has a
different opinion i'd be open to um you
know to other other people's views on
this i i think like my my perspective
right now at this moment
is that
it doesn't seem very productive to me i
feel like a lot of people entering
um ml they want to like actually look
they want to i want to see the
activations you know like i want to see
like you know show me the like the
actual like math that's like happening
and like
i mean i just don't think you can get
much out of that these days like i mean
i think i'm happy people are researching
it i've seen some cool
um you know papers that that um
do seem to have like some insights but
it does seem to me like the more
productive kind of inquiry is stuff like
like like shop where it's more like hey
let's like look at what this thing does
in great detail right and that's kind of
a different way to understand it but i
think also i think like a more maybe
practical way of understanding these
more complicated models and frankly i
think people can't do
um enough of that like seeing like where
it performs where it doesn't perform you
know if i change the training date a
little bit like how does that change you
know what it does like i mean you talk
about these ethical issues and the
ethical issues are always in the
outcomes right like you know like you
would never think that like a like um
i mean someone was telling me that like
you know you'll train a like a language
model and and stuff and and if there's
evocative examples where it's sort of
like
you know like mexican restaurants is
predicting like negative sentiment
because of some like implicit you know
racism i just don't know how you would
like pull that out of like an analysis
of like
you know the
the model itself
it seems like what's really important is
like okay what does the model
actually actually do when you when you
run it you know and so and so that that
just seems to me like a lot more um
productive but hey i think it's great
that people are you know trying to
examine
how these models work in in um in lots
of different ways and if it you know
people figure out ways to actually
like watch you know how the model is
like operating and pull insights from
that it certainly
um
you know would look at that but if
you're if you you know if you have like
if today you have to like figure out
like what a model is doing before you uh
put it into production
um
i would say spend a lot of time looking
at the predictions that it's making
because that's what's actually gonna
happen when it when it goes to
production
so what are the couple of the uh really
big visionary items that are on the road
map uh for for one db that maybe maybe
you haven't even started on yet but
something that you know you'd like to
get to that would be
exciting for our listeners
you know well something like really
exciting um that's that's coming down
the road in the next um in the next
couple quarters is you know we want to
we want to actually reveal a lot more
of our underlying um you know compute
platform to make it um you know really
possible to build
um you know much more exotic stuff on
tops of of weights and biases i think
we've you know we've been kind of
building on our own um internal platform
for for quite a while and it's it's
allowed us to kind of like rapidly um
iterate but you know be kind of behind
the scenes we've been working
really hard on
um
you know exposing more of what we have
and i think we're gonna expose like
um
a lot more over the next couple quarters
and i'm particularly excited about this
because it's just like
the
the diversity of um requests
that we get i just i just can't believe
it you know like i remember like you
know um
like
you know we added a function that i
wondered if i think open it i was
requesting it but i kind of wondered if
anyone else would want it where it's
like you know you can take your like
loss functions and just like plot
arbitrary functions of those loss
functions you know just like in the
graph it felt like a little bit of like
do you really want this i mean like you
know open i requested it and we're like
okay i want to support them and so you
know we have like kind of arbitrary like
expressions um in the product um and
then like tons and tons of people want
it but then it's like you know other
people want to make like completely new
kinds of graphs and then it's like you
know people want to do almost like
arbitrary you know data set explorations
and then like share them you know with
their team and so we've really just felt
this this
pull from the market um you know to make
the tool just like super super flexible
and so um yeah i think it's like we
always have a steady drum beat of kind
of like solution oriented um stuff but
um what i'm i'm really excited about um
you know opening up things to to to
to let people
build more on top of what we have and
and um i think it's gonna be super cool
fantastic
um there's a lot of competitiveness in
the mlop space uh it seems like there
are loads of new companies springing up
all the time one of our friends actually
is starting a company which focuses on
machine teaching and active learning in
ml devops you know rather than seeing it
as a linear kind of non-interactive
process from data to a productionized
model um i mean this is the thing we
were talking about this earlier the ml
devops can be instantiated in so many
different ways depending on the recipe
right every single project is is
different and as you were just saying
that it's heterogeneous compute as well
i mean there are many different
configurations of how this engineering
is set up but i just wondered i mean
based on your vantage point how would
you sum up the competitive landscape
oh wow that's a tough one i i mean
there's um
i guess from my perspective there's like
a couple buckets of stuff um
that i see so
there's kind of like the early companies
that do
what i would call more of a top-down
sale
and we don't run across them that much
even though you know i think they make
you know great products that are really
useful for their customers they tend to
appeal more
to like
you know the the cios or um you know vps
of engineering and if you're you know if
you're running one of those companies i
hope i don't offend you this is truly
like what i what i see in the market um
you know so i see like a like um you
know data robot and like domino
data you know they've you know they've
built big businesses
um with kind of like a like a top-down
sale and like they've really kind of and
like you know if you go to like someone
high in organization that's responsible
for ml what they want is just like look
make my life easy i don't want to buy a
bunch of different kinds of tools i want
to buy like one thing that's going to
basically solve my ml problem and so
what those companies do is they just
sort of like solve your problem you sort
of bet
i feel like you bet your company in a
way on the like
you know data robot data coup and those
are really interesting products but kind
of not what we do and so i'm really not
like a super expert um
you know on these on these things and we
don't really come across them much um in
the market um
then i think there's like there's kind
of the cloud providers offerings which
are like
you know changing all the time right you
know you see like there's like sage
maker and like vertex
and um
uh azure studio and i even start to
maybe put like data bricks in this
category like they're getting big enough
where these are definitely not like kind
of monolithic things that you need to
buy into
um
but it's kind of unclear to me like
where they
begin and
and end you know so it's like i feel
like like you know i'm constantly kind
of updating you know like the the sales
team i'm like okay like how do we like
work with these things and people are
always asking us like okay like how do
you
you know you work with them and the way
that we work with them is like oh it's
changing it also depends on
you know the
you know the customer and how they like
set things up like i i don't know if any
company has like
you know bought every single one of
sagemaker's you know products um and and
even like
you know what people think sagemaker is
is kind of different in different um you
know companies but they have a lot of
adoption all of those do
and it's exciting to see right and then
you see this like explosion of um
of startups kind of all with different
you know points of view like often like
you know kind of solving like one of the
the pieces of a thing that like you know
like i say like might be one of sort of
sage makers like um you know
applications
um and um
and you know you just see like every
possible
like you know take on the market like i
don't know how people
um you know keep track of all this like
i feel like investors like
every week like my own investors send me
this thing like hey what is this like do
you compete with them and it's like man
i like haven't like
i haven't like heard of them you know
and so um
you know
it's it's very very hard to uh
to keep track of i don't know if i have
like any advice to someone that's trying
i don't even know what i would do if i
was like on the other side and i was
trying to um
uh decide i guess i probably had by
weights and biases but you know other
than that
um you know i don't even know how i
would think about it i think there's
attention within companies that
management i think wants to kind of
standardize on one thing
typically the
the researchers want the flexibility to
use like lots of different stuff
um
my approach is to kind of
try to do the best of both worlds where
it's like look like we'll try to have as
many offerings as possible um but make
them work together nicely so that you
know the the bosses can have comfort
that you know weights and devices is a
reasonably complete solution that solves
lots of their problems and they're not
gonna have too many
you know different tools but then
um
the researchers can know like look if
you wanna you know if you wanna swap out
our
um our data set tracking to like
you know a competitive product weights
and biases like you know we're committed
to supporting that and making that you
know work well we obviously can't make
it work quite as well as our own
um product but we also like know that
we can't be everything to everybody and
if you know if people want to use a
different thing for any piece of what we
do we try to make that work well
cool fantastic yeah i was going to ask
about that because in a large enterprise
typically the i.t folks they want to
reduce the technology divergence and
complexity they want to reduce the
number of vendors it's quite difficult
to get you know um ordained in a large
enterprise and and there's this tendency
just to kind of regress
to the um i don't know to sagemaker or
azure ml or something like that so
you'll always be kind of um having this
battle of well how differentiated are
you over say jamaica or azure ml uh what
would you say to that
what i always say is like just try the
products like i i mean if you're not
you know
if you're not convinced i'm i'm not
gonna like talk you into it it takes
five minutes to try weights and biases
just like try it and if it's not like
night and day
use sagemaker experiments you know but
i'll tell you amazon's a customer so
like why is amazon a customer of wasted
biases you know i don't know
great answer great answer
well you heard it here first folks just
try it yeah just try it just go and try
it
here's another question like why would
you use tensorflow like why would you
just wait till my server with tensorflow
then that i get a lot
and i think that
you know i think what wasted biases
really does well is we
we listen really carefully to what
you know ml teams want and we listen
carefully to what you know it teams want
and we we really try to like you know
produce that thing and that's all i'm
thinking about all day long and so you
know if you go like a feature by feature
checklist we have a bunch of features
that i'm proud of but like what i'm
really actually proud of is just that
the thing is like really nice like it's
like a joy to use it like makes all the
things that you typically do like easy
and if you complain we're actually like
listening you know like i mean if you
want to send me an email with like a
feature guys not sure that like we'll
necessarily do it but we're lit we're
listening like carefully and we're
trying to do it yeah that that is a
differentiator
one of the best things for 1db about me
is the community and so we've got sanyum
we've got all of the folks there's a
really really cool slack channel they're
all over the internet actually and
probably it's quite um it's quite
differentiated isn't it i don't really
see that level of social impact from any
other machine learning startup i mean
for example you're sponsoring a whole
bunch of the machine learning uh youtube
channels i mean is is that a core part
of your strategy to like really kind of
show a friendly face and get out there
yes absolutely i mean it's also like a
pretty clear um roi so that that makes
it easy like i think um
you know early on we sponsored two
minute papers and i think we did it kind
of because like a lot of us just like
watched it like you know we were kind of
like thinking like you know
if we're gonna sponsor anything like
let's
um
yeah and and we had this like absolutely
crazy
um sign up rate from from two minute
papers because it was like exactly
you know our our audience and so
you know we have a point of view right
like we called we named our company
waste and biases it's obvious that you
know we went a long time without having
like professional you know marketing
around they probably
you know would have told us to you know
make a name that has a standard
pronunciation that you know it doesn't
have like bias in it when like ethics
and ai is such a big um issue but you
know we wanted to like
take a point of view that um we're
really on the side of the people that
are that are building the the models and
so that's that's the brand i want is
like you know hey this is like a helpful
company that's here like i mean my
feeling is like anyone that wants to
like you know build a model deploy a
model like use ml like i want us to
support them i wanted to have like
useful content for them like i wanted to
you know i want to i want to serve that
group of people and everyone else like
i'd like to help them but they're not a
core audience right so if you're um
you know
if you are an ml practitioner and you
think our website's stupid like let me
know like i want to hear that right but
you know if you're my mom and you think
that my website's like really confusing
like i will listen but i'm not
necessarily going to like change the um
you know the website right or like it's
amazing how many people are like
you know look at my life are like oh
lucas your website like makes no sense
and it's like well look you're not like
our audience you know like the website's
like not you know designed um for you
and so we try to like we're not a huge
company we don't have like a lot of um
marketing resources honestly so it's
great that i mean you actually are our
core audience that's probably why you're
you're seeing us everywhere but i think
most people are like
you know geez for like a like a unicorn
startup like your brand is you know
isn't
isn't really out there but i think
people that are like potential customers
do do feel that way so that makes me
really happy
excellent well folks just try it just
try it uh so maybe shifting gears just a
little bit um i wanted to get your take
on something because uh you said
something interesting
in uh one of your recent blogs
where you know it was really the the
rise of deep learning of neural networks
that kind of changed your mind in a way
on the importance of the algorithms
themselves whereas previously you just
thought hey the data is what matters
algorithms don't really matter so much
but but this rise of deep learning
convinced you that the algorithms
do in fact uh matter and for sure you
know deep learning has succeeded in many
areas however
as we've discussed many times on our
show in fact deep learning is limited
you know not just in practice but it but
theoretically it's limited in in
fundamental ways
and so now that we appreciate the
importance of algorithms themselves i'm
wondering what your take is on on
alternatives for machine learning things
like evolutionary algorithms you know
discrete program search geometric deep
learning you know things like that yeah
are you trying to get me into a
flameware here i feel like sometimes i
like stuff on these third rails they
don't even know exactly i don't know
it's funny because i i think i i it's
funny because like what i studied in
school is like you know bayes nets and
support vector machines and so um
and i remember like you know neural nets
were kind of like
um
you know people were kind of like poo
pooing it even though
i think they were like working pretty
well at the time and so i think like
what i've seen in my life
tells me that like when something is
like working
really pay attention to that and of
course you have to have like a rigorous
definition of working and i think like
you know these evaluations are all
flawed in different ways but i do think
if you have
if you have a useful algorithm
what would get me excited personally is
like if you can find you know a way to
evaluate it where it really does better
than
um
other algorithms like that's like what
i've kind of seen in my life as a sign
of something you know starting to work
and that's that's where i would start to
um
to dig in i mean i'm i'm like sort of
aware of like you know genetic
algorithms working in sort of like um
architecture search and
um but you know i guess i'm
i don't think of myself as kind of a
dogmatic
person here and i get a little
suspicious when people are like oh
surely like you know this approach
should work from first principles
because
like i feel like we've been wrong you
know so many times with that sort of
like line of
reasoning or just what i've seen in my
career is that line of reasoning is
really dangerous and will kind of send
you down
um
you know unproductive
paths but i'm also like look i'm happy
there are lots of people out there
um you know trying stuff and i'm i'll
like cheerlead it you know from the
sidelines i'm a little surprised i feel
like twitter gets a little bit like
nasty on this um
on this topic and i don't totally
understand it like i don't think i like
share other people's sort of like
passion about like a particular
um ml ml approach i mean
i think it'd be really i hope in my life
i get to see a few more waves of um you
know really you know radical new
approaches doing cool things that we
hadn't seen before
well and that's what i'm that's what i
was really exactly kind of asking is and
i'm glad to hear that you know you're
not dogmatic and you would like to see
alternatives so i'm wondering if if you
know one db over time will kind of pay
attention to hey something interesting
over here is going on it's not deep
learning it's not neural networks but
you know we should support that too
because if we make it easier to do that
and try it out it'll help to diversify
the the algorithm space
totally and look we'll integrate with
anything we're always looking you know
for stuff to integrate with and i think
you know i mean my background is really
in boosted trees that's what it did most
in my beginning of my
um you know career so we do in my
opinion we have great boots me too by
the way
yeah yeah cause they they were so
powerful you know like i i mean i
actually i didn't do them at school and
then when i you know i went into
industry i was like wow this is such an
awesome versatile
um
you know like approach i love it so i
you know and and i probably spent more
time with scikit than like any other
um
you know library so
so absolutely like you know we want to
support
you know everything that that you know
that we see and we've hopefully made it
easy for third you know over 9000 github
libraries require weights and biases and
we're happy to work with anyone to
improve the
integration because it helps everyone so
i mean if there's a useful library out
there that we don't integrate with i
would love to know about it because
we'll
we'll we'll ask for an integration i i
think you you easily could pivot in the
future because even for example let's
say deep learning um became obsolete and
we all moved towards
expert systems again um i kind of think
of one db it's not necessarily data it's
it's information right and information
can be events
it can be just people using systems
right it could be absolutely anything so
you know it's an incredible platform for
sharing information and presenting it in
ways which are understandable to
different people so i think you've got
loads and loads of runway there but um
on that issue though i wanted to ask you
a little bit about entrepreneurship and
scaling of business and speaking with
investors and so on and probably like
the main thing when you scale up a
business is this thing that i just said
which is that you need to give people
targets and they need to kind of
vertically give you information and you
were saying earlier you want you want
the graphs to keep going up but not
always right because you've got to give
them targets which are abstract and
understandable but also actually
represent some form of success that
they're actually doing the thing that
you want them to do so i just wondered i
mean you've got a fantastic vantage
point could you tell us about how you
did that
yeah totally you know it's funny peter
wellinger who's like a vp at openai
really like i'm kind of stealing his
points here but they
they really resonated with me
that um i think like actually training
models and running a company
has like a lot of similarities where
you know you have sort of like a limited
amount of resources to
to do to try to get something to happen
and you kind of need to know when to
like cut things off and like you know
how much like it's really like explore
exploit you know trade-off that's like
really kind of tricky and you're always
kind of making decisions without as much
data as you wish because like collecting
more data kind of costs you something so
um you know the way the main way that i
try to manage
is really through um goal setting and so
we're like we're pretty obsessive here
about um
you know kind of work and it's not like
top down goal setting it's like i really
try to work with teams and i what i try
to get is actually like
everyone eventually gets on the same
page through like long conversations
around like you know kind of what goals
make sense i i try to say here's like
things that i really care about right
and these are like you know we want to
make our like anybody use the product
like really happy right you know we
measure that through nps primarily in a
zillion other ways right we also want
like more people to use it right we also
want um you know to to grow our sales
and so like those are things that i
really care about and then i really
tried as much as possible to like
delegate that stuff into the
the individual teams
but also be like super rigorous about
like tracking it right and not in a way
of like hey
um you know if you miss it like you're
fired because i think that actually kind
of breaks the goal set okay people are
afraid of goals i think it can
cause like weird things to happen um so
it really has to be as like hey look
this is what we're trying to do and the
goals are really articulating that and
then like when it's not working we
really want to be like honest with
ourselves and i think a lot of companies
that's where it breaks like you said a
bunch of goals you kind of forget about
them over time or like you know things
kind of change but you're not like
explicit so i think it's like the retros
actually that really make goals you know
powerful so like you know what's a
quarter the whole company gets together
and we look at how well we did and i
actually think from my perspective
that's like the main way that i manage
is through like setting the goals for
the quarter
and then like really thinking about the
retro and then like from that it's like
okay what are the next set of goals um
you know that we set and i think at the
scale that we're at now
there's not a whole lot more that i can
i can do besides you know going on
podcasts and trying to you know spread
the word about what we're what we're
trying to do and hiring great people of
course right that's like you know
those are kind of the key
um
the key things that you that you need to
but you know in a way like
you know when you're trying to like
write a research paper it's like you
actually have this very clear goal
almost it's too clear like usually these
goals are a little bit
um not quite what you would want in like
the real world um but it is like a
similar situation of like you know like
i want to be like the state-of-the-art
um you know with this thing there's sort
of infinite space of like things to try
you know like which part should i be
focused on how do i break it up into
smaller tasks to achieve that um so i
think there's there's a fair amount of
overlap
amazing and by the way i can attest to
lucas's engineers and and
content engineers and and community
evangelists absolutely fantastic team
amazing anyway um lucas thank you so
much for coming on our podcast we really
really appreciate you taking the time
it's been great awesome thank you so
much i'm very proud of this
all right how are we going amazing